Grenda I was obviously the next student
film and actually the whole load of
sequences on the moon yeah we actually
got him to cut because it was going to
go on forever and he had taken him seven
years up at that point anyway and then
we and then you know the BBC said we
thought we'd do another one and we
thought the BBC were keen and for us to
another one so he teamed him up with
Ryan to Bob Baker and one of the things
that Bob did was simply go through his
notebooks and spotted kind of all these
elements which actually became the wrong
trousers you know nikka drawn and his
storyboard and she at pro pro nothing at
all I did 20 or 30 storyboard frames of
that change race sequence the idea of a
model train running for the house he had
drawn and he drawn is the penguin with
rubber gloves so he knew it was kind of
villain and Bob kind of said well it's
all there isn't it it's a heist there's
a big train chase at the end this is not
the story structured and actually wrote
it really quite quickly literally just
putting the elements out of mixed
Nanak's notebook and then it's just a
matter of a kind of storyboarding and
putting it all together and then filming
it but actually the writing of it
probably was the quickest film we'd ever
written as you think